let's bow our heads again for another
word of Prayer
Father in Heaven I know that it's been a
long day for these students it's there's
a lot of learning and and sitting and
not as much
Recreation and yet Lord at the same time
we just we pray your Holy Spirit would
enable us to grasp these topics we're
speaking about
I pray father that your Holy Spirit
would be here to illuminate our minds as
we've discussed already the Revelation
to the prophet the inspiration of the
Prophet is not sufficient if our minds
are not illuminated by your holy spirit
so father please now
for Jesus sake illuminate our hearts and
our minds that we may grasp the
importance then the truth of the subject
we're talking about we ask it in Jesus
name and for his sake amen
okay
before I pick right up where we were I
want to do I want to just take a few
moments to ask because it's going to
help me throughout the rest of the week
if any of you have specific areas that
you have been looking forward to
discussing on the spirit of Prophecy you
knew the spirit of Prophecy was coming
up any of you thinking boy that's good
because I sure have questions about this
or I sure am looking forward to hearing
more about
this is there anything like that where
you have an area that you want
especially that you've been kind of
looking forward to getting more
information on
yes ma'am
okay thank you and that's exactly what
I'm talking about we're going to spend a
good bit of time I'm going to tell you
just uh not to be not to be boastful or
anything but we're going to blow that
plagiarism thing so far out of the water
when we're done it's it's it's uh it's
all of these things look the devil
they're just Scare Tactics the devil's
pulling on us but there's really no
foundation for it but we will spend uh
you will I think you'll you'll you'll
you'll feel very you'll be able to very
confidently talk with your friends about
this one it's all said and done
uh any anything else
something similar yes
applying Ellen White's writings let me
write this down here we're going to talk
about plagiarism
and we will
um
say say again
applying Illinois applying yeah yeah
okay
I really should have put God's counsel
through Ellen White there
uh yes
can right
I mean I'm not laughing at you I just
all right go ahead and then the other
thing was was that I heard
about
some weird things that they were
supposedly doing or something when they
were supposed
to okay it really wasn't and they were
like accusing them of doing
hair typical things okay I don't know
exactly what to write down for that just
uh
maybe I could put accusations
regarding
validity of gift
her like editors
okay kind of plagiarism and uh
liter will put literary assistance
because we'll talk about that too
I'll see well let me count it
yes sir
shut door
boy I like this you know first we just
had we had a fish for one question it's
just like when you make an appeal you
make an appeal for five minutes nobody
does anything somebody comes forward and
then everybody feels like you know what
I need to move forward
I'm gonna put uh development of books
this is this is mainly helping me to jot
this down later so I know that
correlation there yes that like
compilations versus inspiration
you know like similar writing
I'm going to put compilations here with
the books
and I plan on talking about all this but
that's that's good it helps me out to
know where to kind of weigh our
discussion any others
um can you address the issue of her
eating habits
Ellen White's eating habits
now most of you understand that our
prophet
our profit started out as a coffee
drinking pork eating uh uh you know
whatever for
63 was the first Health Vision over 15
years you understand that
so her eating habits and probably how
they developed over and how the health
message developed a little bit
she didn't stay that way by the way
okay
any others
okay we're going to dress we'll be
addressing all of these things uh one
one thing that comes to my mind is
regarding a number of these things a lot
of the misunderstandings come from a
misunderstanding of how the gift of
Prophecy works
for example and I'm not going to get
into the subject now we will talk about
this on this at length but literary
assistance Ellen White had people who
would help her write things and edit
things and they say oh how could she be
a prophet she had people who edited what
she wrote
but when you find out that the Bible
writers had the same thing
and we're going to look at plenty of
text to give you evidence on that we're
going to find out that there's nothing
here that the that if we were to throw
it out with Ellen White we'd have to
throw out the scripture
and the problem is too many people don't
know enough of the scripture and how the
scripture was written and inspired to
know what inspiration's supposed to work
like
and so but we'll get into that
and I appreciate your input there
now we ended up
we were looking at the idea of the
testimony of Jesus being the spirit of
Prophecy Jesus is the one who speaks
through the prophet so far what we've
made mainly established
is that
God a prophet is a spokesperson
primarily
and of all God's methods of
communicating to mankind the prophet has
been his mode of operation his main his
his primary mode of communication
that God communicates his messages
to the prophet in different ways but we
saw the the hierarchy there of God the
Father to Jesus the son etc etc but what
we found last the last thing we looked
at was that primarily the Bible tells us
that the words that come to us through
the prophet
is the testimony of none other than
Jesus Christ himself
so that when we're hearing the counsel
of the Prophet if we follow me here if
we believe the Bible
then we believe that counsel of the
Prophet is the Council of Jesus himself
to reject the Council of the Prophet is
to say Jesus I don't know I don't care
what you have to say
and so you can boast to me all day long
about your love for Jesus and your
Christianity if you're not willing to
listen to his voice through His prophets
and we're going to see this too at
length you're not going to be willing to
listen to his voice anywhere
okay
now that doesn't mean everybody who
claims to be a prophet is a prophet and
we're going to look at the tests of a
prophet
and we're going to do that probably
tomorrow
but let's go on here
and establish a few more things here
with this gift of prophecies Jesus
himself spoke through the prophets
uh let's go to Second Peter chapter 1
and verse 20.
second Peter chapter 1 and verse 20.
right after the book of Hebrews we've
got James first Peter second Peter
second Peter 1 and verse 20 the Bible
tells us this
knowing this verse
that no prophecy of what
of what
scripture is of any private
interpretation for prophecy what kind of
Prophecy
prophecy of scripture
no prophecy uh for prophecy never came
by the will of
man but what
holy men of God spoke as they were what
moved by the Holy Spirit now the only
point I'm going to make right now on
this passage is that
just as God
chose his main method of communication
as being that of the Prophet the office
of prophet
so primarily the work of the Prophet was
communication to us through the
scriptures something you need to
remember and realize is that the
scriptures that you have right now the
Bible that we go by we say we are
bible-believing Christians soul of
scripture the Bible and the Bible only
that Bible and Bible only would not be
in your hands if it weren't for profits
no prophecy of scripture because
prophecy of scripture never came by
anything other than God working through
holy men of old speaking communicating
that message to us that's how the
scriptures came into being do you follow
that okay
and let's look at a couple texts for
that
let's look at Matthew 26 and verse 56
for example
Matthew 26
and verse 56.
this is red letter in my Bible
Jesus speaking here says
incidentally
I've really got to fault myself on what
I just said
there was a time back how many of you
guys remember a guy by the name of Jim
Baker
Jim and Tammy Faye
Jim Baker went into prison
for
fraud basically
when he got out of prison he was an
evangelist a televangelist no it was
while he was in prison I just I don't
know all the story I just remember a
friend of mine telling me was you know
Jim Baker they say in prison he's got
reconverted
and Jim Baker what he's doing is he's
just spending his time going through the
Bible and all he's reading is the red
letter words he's just focusing on the
red letter words and they were telling
me this because they thought this was a
great idea I'm going to go through my
Bible and just read the red letter words
now
that's not so bad I'm not going to fault
you for reading the red letter words but
the idea is he's going to read the red
letter words because those are the words
of Jesus
and I pointed out that the words here in
Red Letters but I made the mistake
because I just got done telling no no no
no the Bible just got done telling us
that everything we read in the Bible is
the testimony of Jesus so just because
it's not in red letter doesn't mean that
it's not Jesus speaking to us anyway
so it says here
look at look at verse 55 with me
Matthew 26 55 in that hour Jesus said to
the multitudes have you come out as
against a robber with swords and clubs
to take me I sat daily with you teaching
in the temple and you did not seize me
but all this was done that the what
scriptures of the prophets might be
fulfilled
and so again the essence of what he's
saying there giving us an Evidence is
that the prophets wrote the scriptures
the scriptures were written by Prophets
so that it's not as I said earlier the
Bible and the gift of Prophecy the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy
the Bible was written by prophets and
the Bible tells us about the prophets
and the Bible directs us to listen and
heed the prophets
another text we'll look at is Romans 1
and verse 2 Matthew Mark Luke John acts
Romans 1
and verse 2.
Romans chapter 1 and verse two we'll
read one and two there verses one and
two
Romans chapter one
verses one and two Paul a bond servant
of Jesus Christ called to be an apostle
separated to the gospel of God which he
promised before through his who
in the where
holy scriptures now this is powerful I
mean we could spend I'm not gonna I
can't I don't have time to really spend
as much time as we could just dwell and
meditate upon all of these passages we
look at but get the gist of what he's
saying he says I'm the great Apostle
Paul speaking forth this gospel message
everybody believes Paul was a was a
powerful gospel evangelist a powerful
gospel writer
but Paul tells us here that the gospel
that God gave to me is that which he
promised before through his what
prophets in the Holy scriptures Paul
says this powerful gospel that I'm
preaching to you I wouldn't even have it
if it were not for the prophets
are you getting a sense of how important
the gift of Prophecy is
this has been God's mode of
communicating Divine truth essential
truths to his people
once again he communicated through His
prophets how they spoke him into our
ears did Paul say God this is the
message I got and God spoke to His
prophets and they came to my door and
they said I'm a prophet let me tell you
about this Paul
is that how they communicated the
message of the Gospel to Paul how did
they communicate it through the
scriptures
okay through the written word
and so
God spoke through prophets and Prophets
primarily spoke through scriptures now
that's not the only place that they
spoke but I'm just trying to give you an
understanding that the Bible that we
hold so dear was communicated to us
through prophets and just I want you to
sense the weight the importance of the
prophetic gift
and having said that I want to tell you
that not every prophet spoke
through the scriptures
there are four types of prophets I'm
going to talk to you about
first of all
there are
canonical Prophets
does anybody know what a canonical
Prophet is
kids
okay can of scriptures what's that
okay these are prophets cannot a
canonical prophet
is a prophet who wrote a book of the
Bible
that's in our Bible okay a canonical
Prophet is a prophet who wrote let me
let me rephrase this here I'll change I
I'll put it this way I usually have
canonical and
literary there's a reason for that
literary means he wrote or she wrote and
canonical means it was included in the
scriptures
name for me some canonical Prophets
Isaiah Jeremiah Ezekiel Daniel okay
you've got the picture
are you clear on a canonical prophet
okay number two
non-canonical
[Music]
non
oops sorry
I don't want to do that one first
non-canonical
literary what is that
I need you to speak up I got a fan
blowing in my ears up here
a prophet who what
okay you wrote a book
but it's not in the Bible
can you tell me a prophet who wrote a
book that's not in the Bible
okay Ellen White and the reason that
we're looking at that that's what we're
looking at we're gonna but before we get
into Ellen White we need to understand
now let me let me ask this if there were
no prophets who ever wrote books that
were not included in the Bible they
wrote things they were literary but it
wasn't but it wasn't included if there
were no such thing as that
would we have a really good biblical
basis for Ellen White
no no the fact is if we have if the
Bible can show us that there were
prophets who wrote things that never
were written in the Bible
that's no different than the spirit than
the gift through Ellen White is it
okay
Enoch
um
well no no because we don't have
evidence that Enoch wrote anything
although there is there is a an
apocryphalic book called the the uh
what is it called The Book of Enoch okay
what else what did somebody say
okay
okay very good
jasher he says here let me give you now
now your book will mention this when you
look at the subject and I forget
specific chapter let me give you one
text that Nails three of them all at
once it's in second chronicles 9 29.
and I'm not going to exhaust this list
for you I just want to give you enough
for you to see from your Bibles that
this is a there are such thing as
non-canonical literary Prophets
second chronicles 9 and verse 29.
now notice what it says here
second chronicles 9 and verse 29. now
the rest of the acts of Solomon first
and last are they not written in the
book of who
Nathan the prophet could could anybody
turn to me to Nathan 1 15 please
yeah
it's not in there is it but the Bible
says he wrote doesn't it is it not
written in the book of Nathan the
prophet look at keep going uh
in the prophecy of what
ahija the Shiloh night
and in the visions of who
Edo The Seer concerning jeroboam the son
of ebat so we've got we've got three
prophets listed there Ito Nathan and
ahija all of which all of whom wrote
books
but we have no record of those books do
you follow that they wrote books they're
literally literary but they are
non-canonical there's nothing the in the
Bible by these fellas now here's another
one that you may not have known of
it's in second chronicles 21 12.
go on just a little bit further second
chronicles 21 12.
this is of special interest to me just
for curiosity's sake I suppose
second chronicles 21 verse 12. notice
what it says
and a letter came to him from who
Elijah the prophet did you know Elijah
the prophet wrote anything
boy wouldn't that be awesome I'd love to
read the book of Elijah oh boy I bet
that would have been a powerful book but
it's not in the Bible is it
it's literary
but not canonical he wrote something but
it's not included in the Bible so we
have examples there are other examples
that I could give of prophets who wrote
but their writings were not included in
the Bible now a third category
you can kind of figure this one out
non-canonical and
non-literary
what does that mean
okay they didn't write anything
and evidently it couldn't be in the
Bible if they never wrote it but they
were prophets and they did have messages
who's a non-literary non-canonical
prophet
okay Jonah Noah John the Baptist Gad is
a prophet that we can name Elisha we
don't have any record that Elisha wrote
anything or no they may have we don't
know for sure but from from the Bible
record we don't have evidence that
Elisha wrote anything that Enoch wrote
anything uh agabus in the New Testament
was a prophet we don't have any book of
agabus we don't have agabus you know
1325 and some testimony
Simeon we don't have Simeon Anna the
prophetess we don't have any record that
they wrote anything okay so you've got
the picture
and and uh those were the I'm sorry they
were the three categories there were not
four there were three that I was going
to look at
uh another note I would make
besides this
is that
besides what we're looking at here
something that that uh
just when we're looking at the subject
of the spirit of Prophecy we have to
realize is that God was not gender
specific when he dealt with prophets
there were prophets and there were
prophetesses
can you name to me some prophets who
were women besides Ellen White
okay Anna Miriam Exodus 15 20 Miriam
okay the four daughters of Philip
four daughters of Philip in Acts 21
verse 9.
who else
Deborah Deborah was a judge and a
prophet holder was a prophet a
prophetess
I was just going to say that was the one
I was going to look up
because that's an interesting one you
know some of them we've heard of look at
Isaiah chapter
8 verse 3.
Isaiah chapter 8 and verse 3. now this
is into this was interesting to me
Isaiah was a prophet
so was his wife
Isaiah chapter 8 and verse 3.
and you can read a little bit more to
get the whole setting here but it says
then verse 3 then I went to the
prophetess and she conceived and bore a
son then the Lord said to me call his
name mayor shalal hashbaz for the child
shall
Etc this being the child of Isaiah this
is Isaiah's wife can you imagine that
household
honey I have a message for you from the
Lord
so do I
have some interesting discussions
around the prophet Isaiah's home so we
have the Bible tells us that there were
women Prophets
you know because you know there are some
people that will challenge us so you
haven't there's no such thing as a women
prophet I'm telling you friends the main
problem here is that people don't
understand what the Bible teaches about
the gift of Prophecy
so they don't know that they're they're
not allowed to be women prophets uh
sorry the Bible tells us all all kinds
of women Prophets You need to tell the
lord they're not allowed you know he
made some mistakes here because he's got
a lot of them in the Bible
there are more that they could be
mentioned uh yes and by the way Ben you
mentioned Deborah judges 4-4
tells us that Deborah was a prophetess
now some of these prophets and this is
just kind of uh incidental information
it's not essential but it's interesting
some of these prophets were
contemporaries that is they they were
prophets at the same time period
okay can somebody tell me who's some
contemporary prophets were
okay Daniel and Ezekiel were
contemporaries
who else was contemporary with Daniel
and Ezekiel
Jeremiah
now this is important listen to me a
contemporary prophet and why this is
important we'll look at a little bit
later is
when we are looking at the gift of
Prophecy
and we're saying a Seventh-Day Adventist
we need to look into the councils of
what Alan white says and somebody says I
don't need that I just got my Bible and
that's all I need
do we find the Bible prophets doing that
do we find Daniel doing that
why don't you hey Daniel why don't you
read what Jeremiah the prophet says
I'm not going to read Jeremiah the
prophet I got my Bible and that's all I
need I didn't ask that what Daniel said
I got the Bible in the Bible only no
Daniel understood that Jeremiah was a
prophet and that's why in Daniel chapter
9 what do we find we find Daniel
studying the Prophecies of the Prophet
Jeremiah who was at the time
non-canonical and literary
in Daniel's day Jeremiah was not in the
Bible
is that right what about in Paul's day
when Paul issued something to the church
Paul had the gift of Prophecy
I'm not going to listen to Paul he's not
in the Bible the Bible ends with Malachi
and that's all I'm listening to
right I said you don't find that you got
to put you you got to remember that that
just like in Daniel's day Jeremiah was
not in the Bible but he was a literary
prophet and Daniel studied that literary
prophet and followed what he said
and in Paul's day though Paul was not in
the Bible he was literary and they
studied that prophet and did what he
said
of course now they've been included in
the Canon of scripture but they weren't
at the time
did that give anybody an excuse for not
studying their writings at the time
did God not expect anybody to follow the
writings of Jeremiah or Paul until they
were canonical
until they were canonized no God
expected when the prophet spoke that
they listened to the prophet
because remember some of these prophets
weren't canonical or literary but God
still expected their message to be
heated amen
okay
so some were contemporary some other
contemporary prophets uh the New
Testament has a number of them you have
uh I put
oh ananias
who came to the Apostle Paul
himself Silas Judas Philip's four
daughters and John were all prophets
living at the same time
there are all kinds of prophets in the
New Testament Church
Peter
yeah Simeon Simeon uh-huh
yeah exactly I mean he wasn't a
contemporary necessarily because he you
remember when he was in contemporated
with Paul because he said now I can go
to my rest because I've finally seen the
Messiah Lord allowed him to live long
enough to see the birth of the Messiah
he was a contemporary with Anna that's
right so you got the idea of
contemporaries those are some
types of profits and the reason that
we're looking at all this is try to get
a Bible understanding of how the gift of
Prophecy worked
so that when we deal with the idea that
today you and I believe that God has
sent a woman
literary non-canonical Prophet we have
biblical evidence for believing in such
a thing you follow that okay
what I want to finish up with today
is talking about the role
of the prophets
why did God send the prophet now we
could say well to give us understanding
obviously the prophet was how he
communicated but why did God send the
prophet what was the role of the prophet
in the church
and I want to look at some scriptures
for that this morning number one
we're going to go to Ephesians 2
and verse 20.
Ephesians 2 and verse 20.
Matthew Mark Luke John acts Romans first
and second Corinthians Galatians
Ephesians
Ephesians 2 and verse 20.
we'll start in verse 19. that's kind of
in the middle of a verse
Ephesians 2 and verse 19 will start
I know that really messes you guys up
you go down you write down 220 and then
I change it and then you gotta foreign
you might have to you might have to just
give me a little bit of uh leeway on
that and just wait till we get to the
actual text and say I know where Pastor
Howard's gonna he's gonna say 220 we'll
get there and say you know what about
19. oh let's go back to 18. why don't we
just start at verse 15.
so Ben you know all about that
okay
but we're gonna go to 19 Ephesians 2
verse 19.
now it says now therefore you are no
longer strangers and foreigners but
fellow citizens with the Saints and
members of the household of God
having been built on the what
foundation of the Apostles and Prophets
Jesus Christ what himself being the
Chief Cornerstone in whom the whole
building being fitted together grows
into a holy Temple to the Lord in whom
also you are being built together for a
Dwelling Place
of God in the spirit now here's the
point he says in verse 20 having been
built on the foundation of the Apostles
and Prophets Jesus Christ himself being
the Chief Cornerstone the Cornerstone
was the peace that kept everything
together and Paul himself says there's
no other Foundation that can be laid but
that which is lay the foundation of
Jesus Christ the point that's being made
here is that Foundation of Jesus Christ
was solidified was laid through the
teaching of Apostles and Prophets
and so one role that God gave to the
prophet was to lay the foundation of the
church
they're not the foundation of the church
but their teachings are they're the
teachings about Jesus Christ do you
follow that they're the teachings of
Jesus Christ the testimony of Jesus and
so an important role for the prophetic
gift was they were to lay the foundation
of the faith
how important is the foundation if
you're going to build then
any any of the rest of you work in a
construction trade I know Leonard you
did you did I used to work in the
construction trade you can't do much
without a foundation can you
you're not doing a lot of building until
the foundation is laid how important is
the gift of Prophecy
I tell you brothers and sisters and and
the devil is working like nobody's
business today to tear apart the
foundation
and we've got Seventh-Day Adventists who
ought to know better who are throwing
out the gift of prophet so I don't need
that I just need my Bible
hello
it's time to be awake and alert and
aware of the gift that God has given to
his church to be aware of all the
teachings God has given that Jesus said
that we are to take heed to all the
prophets have spoken well
one role of the Prophet was to lay the
foundation of the church along with the
apostles
Paul lists here in Ephesians 2 20. now I
want you to go with me to the work to
the to the book of Ephesians still in
Ephesians chapter four
chapter four we're going to start in
verse 11. we'll spend a little bit of
time going through verse 11. now verse
11 is talking about spiritual gift it's
not just it's not just narrowing it down
to the gift of Prophecy alone
Paul's talking about several gifts of
the Spirit
but he's telling us the purpose of these
gifts and I really want you to catch the
purpose of the gifts here as Paul
outlines it in Ephesians 4.
Ephesians 4 verse 11.
he's speaking of Jesus Christ himself
verse 10 he who descended and that's
Jesus verse 11 he himself gave some to
be Apostles some prophets some
evangelists some pastors and teachers
the other these are the gifts why did he
give them these gifts next verse
for the equipping of the Saints for the
work of ministry what's the first reason
okay
equip Saints
for Ministry
we're going to spend a little more time
after we list some of these out
for the equipping of the Saints for the
work of Ministry for the edifying of the
body of Christ what's the body of Christ
the church what does it mean to edify
to build up to encourage I mean it's
going to put to encourage
the church
okay
sound good
for the edifying of the body of Christ
till we all come to the unity of the
faith and of the knowledge
of the son of God
until we all come to the what
follow this
to bring
doctrinal
Unity
I'm going to embellish that a little bit
as we go
to the union of faith and to the
knowledge of the son of God
I need to let you guys give me these
what does that mean
to the knowledge of the son of God
till we come two things till we come to
the unity of the faith and till we come
to a knowledge of the son of God
how would I sum that up
clear Revelation I know you guys can
talk louder than this
I heard you during the break
to do what
to know Jesus
better understanding
because by beholding
we become changed from Glory to Glory
right so to give us a better
Fuller understanding
what I want to say bring
to
and that this is kind of fleshed out too
in the next passage okay
uh
so we all come to the unity of the faith
and the knowledge of the Son of God to a
perfect man
to the measure of the stature of the
fullness of Christ
so not only to bring us to a full
understanding but just as we said as we
behold what
to bring to
character
maturity
in Christ
are you following this are you seeing
this out of your Bibles
I don't want you saying we're Pastor
Howard get that one from
we're just we're just trying to
we're just rephrasing what Paul has put
down here in Ephesians these are the
purpose for all the spiritual gifts not
just the gift of Prophecy but we want to
include that here
I like verse 14. that we should no
longer be children tossed to and fro and
carried about with every wind of
Doctrine
by the trickery of men in a cunning
craftiness of deceitful plotting but
speaking the truth in love may grow up
in what
in all things into him who is the head
Christ so that's talking about the
character maturity and what he says here
that we may not be tossed to and fro
with every wind of Doctrine to bring us
to doctrinal Unity to preserve us from
doctrinal confusion
now
have you ever heard people say we don't
want to use Ellen White
to clarify our doctrines
have you ever heard people say that is
that biblical
is it biblical to say we're not going to
use Ellen White to clarify our doctrines
what did we just read
is the role is one of the roles of the
gift of Prophecy to bring us to
doctrinal Unity how's that going to
happen if the prophet says nothing about
Doctrine and we don't regard what the
prophet says in context of Doctrine can
that happen
to bring to doctrinal Unity is the gift
of Prophecy given to give us clear
understanding on our doctrines yes is
the prophet given to base our doctrines
upon no
the scripture is given to base our
doctrines upon and the scripture told us
that God would send a prophet to give us
clear understanding on the scriptures
Doctrine
do you follow that
are there any questions on that
now I was told this was a really good
class
said man Pastor Howard this is an
excellent class this this session
you know what makes a good class
they're not afraid to ask questions
absolutely
let me tell you something when a person
asks a question
those of you are sitting there saying I
don't want to be the idiot to ask that
question when you ask the question the
rest of the class says I'm glad somebody
asked that question I'm just telling you
right now so don't you worry about
asking the question if and if somebody
wants to think you're an idiot for
asking a question
guess what you're going to go out of the
class knowing the answer
and down the road when you need it
you'll have it to rephrase
there are people and you you may not
have heard this now if you haven't you
will
that Ellen White should not be used
in in the interpretation of the
formation of our doctrines now there's
an element of Truth in that and that is
we don't base the Adventist Church
doesn't base his teachings on Ellen
White
I've given Evangelistic meeting after
meeting after meeting after meeting I
never quote Ellen White my Ventures I
don't need two I preach it from the
Bible I can teach anything including the
spirit of Prophecy from the Bible but
the question is does the gift or
prophecy have anything to do with the
formation of the church's doctrines
according to this passage this is all
based on Ephesians 4.
does it yes the Bible tells us that one
of the things that the gift of Prophecy
is going to do is bring us to a Unity of
the faith
a Unity of the faith means a Unity of
what we believe
in other words
um well we'll talk more we're going to
actually talk more about the role of the
of the spirit of Prophecy and how this
happened in our early church
but to restate
one of the gifts of Prophecy
is to bring the church to a Unity of
doctrinal understanding what do I mean
doctrinal what's Doctrine
teaching that's all it is Doctrine means
our teachings
and when I say our teachings I mean
whatever seven of the heavens believe
our basic Bible truths they're not our
teachings but they're what we believe
the Bible teaches yes sir
those little small little debates
nuances that she doesn't want to be I
guess
and we will discuss that at length a
little bit later as to how Ellen White
was
expected her writings to be regarded in
the solving of doctrinal issues and how
she expected them not to be used okay
but what I'm in and so I'm not talking
to the to the to every aspect of this
now what the only point I want to make
or rather the only point I want you to
see that the Bible makes
is that one of the roles of the gift of
Prophecy is to give us a doctrinal
understanding for example
you've got you've got uh you and I read
a passage we all read a passage of
scripture we come up with what do you
think that means and we come up with six
different ideas here
who's right well you say my Bible says
uh my Bible says uh-uh my Bible says and
all of us read it in the Bible and we've
got six different ideas
now it's all biblical
so how do we know where the truth lies
this is where God would use a prophet to
clarify when his people were going off
course and say pardon me that's not what
I said
you know the role the prophet was always
to bring people back to the word
okay and I want to tell you something
now you may know that not know this this
may be news to you today
but you and I have a tendency to
interpret the Bible according to the way
we want to hear it
did you know that
I've had people tell me I'm going to
tell you this I'll tell you this right
now I think I can be safe here without
really being offensive to anybody
but the Bible teaches us the Bible has a
teaching regarding being unequally yoked
together with unbelievers
and I can't tell you how many times
somebody wants to come to me and say oh
but Pastor my case is different
you don't understand I know what the
Bible says there but and we have a
tendency to say in every other case I
believe that but in my case when I read
the Bible I don't really think it's
saying exactly what you think it says
we tend to interpret the Bible according
to how we want it to he how we want to
hear it or what we want it to say do you
understand what I'm saying and so God
has always sent the prophet to come and
clarify those things because the Bible
says the
heart is deceitful above all things and
desperately wicked you know the passage
the heart is deceitful above all things
and desperately wicked who can know it
are you familiar with that Passage and
so the question who can know it and then
what's the answer
you know what comes after that
the heart is to sleep above all things
and desperately wicked Jeremiah 17.
we're going to finish up on this thought
we're going to pick up on this subject
tomorrow because we've reached our
we've reached your limit
this will be our last text
Jeremiah I want you to get this Jeremiah
chapter
what did I say
yeah
Jeremiah 17 verse 9. okay
and somebody want to read that for me
okay what's the answer
I the Lord
I the Lord he says search the heart I
test the mind
God says your heart's deceitful you say
but my heart tells me look my heart
tells me this relationship is perfect
Lord
and he says you don't know what your
heart your heart's deceitful and
desperately wicked who can know it well
what am I supposed to do let's say hey
I know your heart
I search the heart I try the Reigns
come to me and I'll reveal to you the
true state of things
and it's dangerous for you and I to do
anything different
we have a perfect example with the
Apostle Peter
Jesus comes to the Apostle Peter says
Peter Peter says Lord they may all
forsake you but I'm going to die for you
and the Lord says Peter you're going to
deny me before the rooster crows you're
going to deny me three times
and what's Peter tell Jesus
you're wrong Lord
Peter this is what you're going to do
Lord you don't know me like I Know
Myself Lord you may think this but I
know me better than you and I'm not
going to deny you
who was right
the Lord was
it's the same thing see and the Lord
comes to one of the reasons for the
prophetic gift in the scripture and in
the spirit of Prophecy is that God
reveals to us the truth of the matter
and helps us to come to a doctrinal
Unity as he strips away our selfish
interpretations and helps us to see
clearly what the Bible is really trying
to get across to us you follow that
now is is that something I made up
is that something the general conference
handed down and said if you're going to
be a Seventh-Day Adventist you got to
believe this
where'd you get it
the Apostle Paul told us in Ephesians 4
under inspiration of the Holy Spirit
amen
so you you can choose different you say
well I don't care what you say Pastor I
I'm not going to use the the spirit of
Prophecy to help me to get a clear
understanding of scripture fine you're
not following what the Lord says in his
word I mean the Lord is trying to help
us to understand how these things work
you know we're not we're not I'm not
here inventing things you're not hearing
venting things we're trying to
understand Lord how would you have us to
understand how this gift works you
understand that okay good can you retain
that until tomorrow
all right good what I'm going to do on
your way out I know you're not going to
be appreciative of this
which app are you going to read
okay
I've got this outlined as you've all
been taking notes and somebody can say
oh man but you know I don't want to hand
out the outline to begin with because
then what happens then you don't take
notes and then what happens you don't
retain as much Okay so
get a handout on your way out
um on what we've covered today and uh
let's have a word of prayer Pastor
Wallace could you offer a word of prayer
for us in closing today
Father in heaven we thank you so much
for being so good to us in so many ways
but especially we're thankful for giving
us the gift of Prophecy amen if we ever
needed it before we sure do need it now
amen
especially when it comes to doctrinal
Unity amen oh Lord does every windowed
Doctrine belong through this church
and I am just so very very thankful
that you have given us an inspired
commentary on scripture
that can help us if we will let him come
to rightly divide the word of Truth
and I thank you so much
for this new seminar that's just
beginning for my brother's emphasis here
and I pray a continued blessing upon him
and I pray that each one here
might take to heart what they are
learning and Come Away with such a solid
confidence in the precious gift of the
testimony of Jesus Remember Spirit of
Prophecy that nothing will be able to
shake that
oh Lord the devil's trying so hard to
pull out that
that Foundation from this church
please help us not to let him do that
amen thank you for hearing this prayer
and granting my request for asking in
Jesus name amen amen